preservation of a slice of Americana of
a childhood dreams every every boy and
most most girls I'd imagine want want to
have a treehouse US Army Specialist Mark
graben promised his two sons a treehouse
when he returned from his tour of duty
in Iraq I must have drawn some very into
this treehouse a hundred if not a
thousand times grape and contacted
Fairfax's building code office for
permission and the guy kind of laughed
me off the phone come on down write a
big check I'll be glad to take all your
money but it's a tree house there's no
building codes for a treehouse just keep
your kids safe but then the Zoning Board
received an anonymous complaint and
demanded the treehouse to be taken down
graben went to the board for a permit
the board said they don't have the
latitude to issue such things not to a
treehouse that's when things took off I
had asked for perhaps the help of the
local media and and a humble local
request just exploded in international
attention public interest led to an
online petition 1600 people over the
course of a month or so responded to
that online petition one neighbor even
donated concealment trees it hopes to
appease the board graben had one last
appeal before the treehouse came down
when they reahard and reconvene to
reconsider in our favor it was unanimous
decision thanks to public outcry the
decision was a five-year permit for the
treehouse the last generation we do not
remember an entire neighborhood getting
together like this all at once it's that
kind of sense of community sense of
neighborhood sense of friendliness and
it's it's terrific
you